IQ tests have been controversial over the years. One of the major concerns is,
are IQ rests reliable and valid measures of intelligence? Now the simple answer
to is an IQ test a reliable measure, is yes. IQ test will produce consistent,
meaning reliable, scores over time. In fact, the reliability of IQ tests are
among the highest in social sciences. Now, how they find this, is they look at
people's score at one point in their life, and then they compare it to their
score at another point in their life. And even though time has passed, they
find that the scores they have on IQ tests at different times are highly
correlated. This shows that it's reliable. However, just because it's reliable
doesn't mean there might not be problems with validity. So let's go back to
Susan to talk about the validity of an IQ test.